Time management skills will improve only
when you practice. If someone tells you
to incorporate this thing, your time
management will improve. No,
time management will improve only and only
when you solve as many
questions as possible. See.  When we
study theory, an understanding is
developed regarding the topic, but
when we solve questions on the same theory, we refine the
understanding that has been
developed and if I want to
solve that question specifically, then that is.
Needs a different kind of
temperament in your brain and
how to remove that temperament very quickly, you will
understand it only with more practice, so a
very simple solution for time management
is just this: practice, practice,
practice as much as you want.  The more you
practice questions, the more you will start feeling yourself.